welcome to other Thank You Thursday I
believe that it's important to thank the
people who've had an impact on your life
on your business you can't do this alone
and it's nice to every now and then just
say thank you to people so today I want
to thank the fine people at macgregor
point macgregor point is a camp site
that is three hours north of Toronto and
every now and then it's nice to get away
right as entrepreneurs we're pouring
everything we have into our businesses
we can get stressed out you know we want
to be better be higher achieve more and
we we kill ourselves sometimes it's nice
to unplug and relax so I decided that I
would surprise my wife picked up from
work one day and and drive off McGregor
point for some winter yurt camping now
yours are these little Hut's almost
their native huts that they have
electricity and some heat so you can
stay there in the winter but every time
I go camping first I've never done in a
yurt and my wife usually plans all the
details and so here I am having to plan
everything myself and I called them up
and I said you know I had a million
questions what are we need to bring I
said I've never done this before using
my wife plans everything I'm freaking
out what do we need to bring to make
this trip a success because it's
supposed to be a surprise for my wife as
a relaxation weekend and and and the
person went to the phone she laughs a
little bit and then she told me exactly
what I needed to bring I still packed
way too much stuff because when you're
packing for women you never know what
they're going to need and so I packed
everything basically for one weekend and
when I got there you know I let them
know that that I was going to be late
you know that we missed a check-in
because checking the latest time you get
check in is eight o'clock and we're
going to be past that and I'll let them
know on the phone before hand and when
we got there they had made sure that the
lights were turned on for us that the
heat was already turned on for us we can
have a great first experience walking in
we went the next day to check in and
they were super helpful and we're
telling us what to do in the city what
we could do around the area and just
overall a fantastic experience and
really made our weekend gave us a chance
to unplug and relax and so all the fine
people at macgregor point thank
you so much for your help you don't
typically expect amazing customer
service from a government organization
so I really appreciate that thank you
for making a weekend special from the
bottom of my heart and for those of you
watching take time today to thank
somebody who's had an impact on your
business on your life it'll make them
feel great it'll make you feel great it
doesn't have to take long send an email
make a phone call do a video send a
thank you note whatever it is do
something to make somebody who's helped
you feel a little bit special and you
will all experience fantastic karma this
week believe those you're watching like
a video you can see more just like it by
subscribing to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon don't forget to
click here to subscribe to my newsletter
to get actionable inspiring motivational
believe advice every single week to your
inbox hi I'm Jason guis fonseka of ra's
online com and i want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring XD only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period